this hoverboard has been giving us some
issues it won't really like to turn one
way
it's also been decelerating really funky
and so i'm just opening it up to see if
there's anything that needs to be
tightened if something needs to be
adjusted maybe a potentiometer is not
doing its job just opening up seeing if
i can diagnose anything and hopefully
make it better
look at those electronics
well there's our there's there's our
problem all those dust bunnies uh what
determines tilt
it's got a jesus clip on it the jesus
clip is a clip that goes around a
cylinder that clips on and the reason
why they call them jesus clips is
because every single time you take one
of them off or try to put one on they
always go flying somewhere else and you
just kind of juice
i like how this is uh like a normal
airsoft battery more or less
so kevin what's a better name for one of
these than otherwise
better segway
so you just kind of do like process of
elimination be like well these are the
things that have to exist exactly so
what could this be that side looks easy
but this side looks like a mess okay so
you have to assume then at that point
that this is has to be a control board
over here since it's more circuitry
obviously not the battery this it has to
be responsible for controlling i can
take it a step further because
i
know a little bit more about electronics
and these guys right here this is what
controls and regulates the voltage that
is sent to the wheels so this is a power
setup
that controls and regulates the power
to the tires
that's pretty cool
yeah oh
uh so it looks like that this is the
part that comes down to let you know
whether you're on the hoverboard or not
so this is a guess a dual purpose like
that looks like an imu right there
inertial motion unit it's what detects
what angle things are at to a relative
degree kind of measures gravity
acceleration and it has like a gyroscope
inside this
that's an antenna
why why would there be an antenna
inside of a hoverboard illuminati has a
very real historical foundation in 1776
in bavaria germany adam weishaupt a
german professor inspired by the ideals
of french philosophy namely secularism
and rational thought decided to form an
organization to protect those beliefs
what if the illuminati was officially
prescribed more than 200 years ago but
if we pay close attention to subsequent
events
we shall find an alarming succession of
coincidences look it even says a-n-t
antenna
so everything that's not on the shelf
where it's supposed to be is gonna get
either thrown in the prop room on the
floor where it goes if it's a prop or if
it's a camera room put it on the table
in the camera room or if it's wardrobe
put it right here and gabe's gonna take
it all out we're going into code red get
the studio organized mode it's happening
right now spent all this time and money
getting this place cleaned up
i come back into the prop room and this
is what i see
[Music]
the [ __ ] is this
look at this
what the [ __ ] is that
they have two hours to fix the studio
perfect order right from right now two
hours uh we just moved to the ping pong
table back up and the dining room table
back up
there's a lot of stuff it's gone it's
all clear now we're just trying to take
down everything off of these shelves and
because there's plenty of space up here
but there's just so much like random
things like occupying the same space as
other things that we wanted to take all
those things off isolate them
one good thing about cleaning is that
you actually find some pretty cool stuff
that was lost in piles
found
sweet pipe and harry potter's
wand
right now the plan is to figure out
exactly which direction these things are
off by the exact number when we put it
back together offset it by that same
amount by either shimming something
under it or see if we can shim the board
itself
i just took off these things and powered
everything back on and what i'm doing is
i'm using my imu inside my phone as a
leveling system here i can get how level
something is and it gives me a readout
of how many degrees it goes this case
should be level so if i set this on top
of the case
and i hold it level that should mean
your feet are level on the hoverboard so
if i take this and i hold it level right
there is level
but it's saying speed exceed
i have to hold it at about four degrees
off i think that has to do with uh why
you can't turn as fast one way or the
other so it was weird as i thought oh if
you press down on one it enables both of
the wheels but actually you have to sit
down on both and i'll get both
so let's go and do a quick test on this
wheel
now they're both off by four degrees
that'd be fine but this one's only off
by
like 1.5
that means you could actually spin
really fast on one of these so hopefully
this means all i have to do is go into
here and when i put this back on try to
figure out a way to readjust it so that
this is offset by the same amount of
degrees that the imu is off with level
ideally we'd be able to do this in
software i don't see a usb port on here
to connect to to reprogram it so
we're going to do with the old fashion
live my hope is that the studio is nice
and clean and things are back where
they're supposed to go now that sounds
easy but trust me it's not
gotta get the old boots on
this morning i asked gabe and derek to
clean up the studio
i gave him a few hours let's see where
they're at
oh that looks pretty good it didn't look
like that before pretty good overall
shelf slip generally
in order just that looks pretty good all
the tools are back in order that's
always good to see gun wall it's about
95 it needs a little restacking but
other than that
and back here
the real deal so basically the system
that we're trying to have here is every
shelf has a label for right now i mean
we can change these but it's going to be
p1 p2 p3 p4 it stands for props you know
prop 1 pop 2 and everyone will have you
know certain amount of bins on them that
are tailored to a specific type of prop
that you might need so p1 is all head
stuff stuff that we can actually put on
actors we have headphones we have
sunglasses and glasses and we have wigs
and then from p2 it'll be probably like
stuff you can hold or wear that isn't
necessarily on your face so we're just
trying to figure out how to de-randomize
everything we're going to have a sheet
that we're going to hopefully post right
here onto the door
that'll have just a list that says all
right in p1 you can find these items
right here and then p2 you can find
these items so that way when somebody
comes in here and they're like oh no i
don't even know what to look for and
look at the itinerary it's right there
boom bam
boom
boom big bad boom in the cab here look
so did they complete the task of
organizing the whole studio in two hours
the whole studio i don't know i don't
think so i don't think that's a written
i don't i don't think
[Laughter]
if i can recall jake said
just this area first
we were out in the world we might have
to look back at the footage on that one
after this it's just a whole lot of
painting i'm i'm happy though i'm happy
a lot of progress we kind of hit a
stalemate so that that antenna that we
saw down here
it goes to a remote control for the
hoverboard that remote control is the
only way to reset the imus i tried
stuffing the stuff in underneath i'm
used to like make them level but the
issue with that is it's too much i can't
actually put everything back on because
we're having to tilt the imus way more
than they're supposed to it worked but i
can't put the case back on we're just
going to put it back together as is and
see if we can get a new remote or
something all the other hoverboards
every last one of them except for the
stupid iohawk lets you reset it with the
button uh the on off button
but this is the only one that requires
you to have a remote they never gave us
the remote so
we can't reset it
i did switch the imus so hopefully they
drift the opposite way and if they do
then maybe it'll level out eventually
[Music]
you